have you ever wondered what does Islam
say about Jesus can Muslims really be
the Antichrist if they believe in get
this believe in and love Jesus I'm very
confident that if you gave some time to
hearing our view on Jesus that it would
really intrigue you and make much sense
to you now Jesus as we know is a figure
who is loved and revered by billions of
people the world over yet there is much
confusion surrounding the status of this
colossal personality Muslims and
Christians both hold Jesus in high
regard
but view him in very different ways
let's first look at the idea of Jesus as
God some Christians claim that Jesus is
God or a part of a Trinity that he is
the incarnation of God on earth and that
God took on human form however according
to the Bible Jesus was born he ate slept
prayed and had limited knowledge all
attributes not befitting God God has
attributes of perfection
whereas man is the opposite how could
anything be to complete opposite
simultaneously that doesn't make sense
Islam on the other hand teaches that God
is always perfect to believe that God
became a man is to claim that God is or
was at some point in time imperfect
that's why a Christian must ask him or
herself does that idea of God who was
once a week helpless child one who could
not survive without food drink or sleep
be the same
Almighty God described in the Old
Testament surely not my friends one may
ask if God can do anything
why can't he become a man now by
definition God does not do ungodly acts
please understand this God does not do
anything that would make him something
other than God if God became man and
took on human attributes he would as a
result no longer be God now we do
understand some ambiguous verses the
Bible can be applied erroneously meaning
incorrectly forcing to fit
to show that Jesus is in some way divine
but if we look at the clear distinct
verses of the Bible we see again and
again that Jesus is being referred to as
an extraordinary human being a prophet a
messenger the Messiah Norton when
translated Christ and that is exactly
the Islamic view on Jesus he was all of
these but in no way shape or form did
Jesus ever claim to be God Almighty or
did he call to be worshipped alongside
with God remember this is important
Jesus he only called people to worship
the one God full-stop you'll notice is
the Bible with all due respect though
it's been changed edited tampered with
by man and this is confirmed by many
Bible scholars and his basic knowledge
in textual bible seminary school it does
still contain many verses in which Jesus
speaks and behaves as if God is set a
separate being to himself for example 1
Jesus fell on his face and prayed
Matthew 26:39 the question is if Jesus
was God then would God fall on his face
and pray and who would he be praying to
- the Bible calls Jesus a prophet
Matthew 21 10 so how could Jesus be God
and be God's prophet at the same time 3
Jesus said I'm going to the Father
because the father is greater than me
this is in John 14 28 jesus said I
ascend unto my father and your father
and to my god and your God this is in
John 20:17
and who was he ascending to for now if
Jesus was God he would clearly he would
have clearly told people to worship Him
and there would be clear verses in the
Bible stating this yet he didn't the
opposite and disapproved of anyone
worshiping him it stated that Jesus said
in vain do they worship me this is in
Matthew 15:9 now this was all set with
the deep love and respect for Jesus and
for our Christian friends and all the
not yet Muslims because everyone has it
in them to willingly submit to the will
of God that's what a Muslim is and Islam
means submission to the will of God and
that is exactly what Jesus did this is
Jesus the mighty messenger a prophet of
God in Islam whom we love please don't
forget to like and share also do your
best to help us reach our goal for more
info check in to the description below
and in the words of jesus Shalom Salaam
peace be with you
you